GOOD MORNING.
THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SOMEONE
HEARING.
ON MAY TWENTY FOURTH
I'D LIKE TO START BY
ESTABLISHING CORN.
ARAMBULA. PRESENT HARPER.
MATHIS.
RATHER. RUBIO HERE WOULD.
I'D LIKE TO START BY SAYING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH HEALTH
AND THEN GO TO HUMAN SERVICES.
WE ARE GOING TO BE BATCHING THE
PROPOSAL'S HERE TODAY IF THERE'S
ANY CONFUSION THAT PEOPLE HAVE
FOLLOWING ALONG.
OUR STAFF WILL BE.
PRESENTING THEIR RESULTS AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN AND YOU'RE
MORE THAN WELCOME TO FOLLOW UP
WITH US AS NEEDED.
I WANTED TO SAY SOMETHING CUES
IF I COULD PARTICULARLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT DIRECTORS.
AS WELL AS TO THE DEPARTMENT
STAFF MANY OF THE DIRECTORS.
MAY BE RETIRING SOON AND.
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK AND WANTED ADAM
PERSONAL THANK YOU TO DIRECTOR
LIGHT BORN AND MANY OF THOSE WHO
MAY NOT BE COMING BACK NEXT
YEAR.
FINALLY I WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND ALEJO WHO HAVE BEEN
WONDERFUL PARTNERS THROUGHOUT
THIS ENTIRE YEAR AND HELPING US
TO SHAPE THIS BUDGET.
AGAIN I WANTED TO THANK ARE
REPUBLICAN CONSULTANT WHO'S HERE
ALEX CAN AS WELL AS OUR TO
DEMOCRATIC CONSULTANTS WHO HAVE
NAMEPLATES FINALLY. AFTER AWHILE
BUT ANDREA MARGOLIS AND NICOLE
VASQUEZ HAVE BEEN WONDERFUL TO
WORK WITH AND REALLY ENJOYED TO.
PUT THIS BUDGET TOGETHER SOME.
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW BEGIN OUR
HEARING AND START WITH BATCHES.
WITH HEALTH CARE WE ARE GOING TO
SUPPORT OUR COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ITEMS. OR
ISSUES ONE THROUGH SIX.
TEN TWELVE THROUGH FIFTEEN.
SEVENTEEN THROUGH NINETEEN.
TWENTY ONE THROUGH TWENTY FOUR.
TWENTY SIX THREE TWENTY SEVEN.
THIRTY ONE THREE THIRTY SIX.
THIRTY EIGHT.
FORTY THROUGH FIFTY FIVE.
FIFTY SEVEN THROUGH SIXTY FIVE.
SIXTY SEVEN TO SIXTY NINE.
SEVENTY THREE THROUGH SEVENTY
FIVE.
SEVENTY EIGHT THROUGH EIGHTY
TWO.
EIGHTY FOUR THROUGH NINETY NINE.
ONE OH ONE THROUGH ONE FIFTEEN.
ONE SEVENTEEN EVERYONE TWENTY.
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA HIGH HARPER.
MATHIS BY RUBIO I WOULD I.
NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO BATCH
ISSUES.
EIGHT THROUGH NINE.
FIFTY SIX
SIXTY SIX AND ONE HUNDRED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA AYE HARPER.
MATHIS NO RUBIO I. WOULD BUY.
NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE US
BATCH
ISSUES SEVEN. ELEVEN.
TWENTY FIVE.
THIRTY SEVEN.
SEVENTY ONE.
SEVENTY TWO AND ONE SIXTEEN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
AYE HARPER.
MATHIS.
.
RUBIO.
WOULD.
NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO BATCH
ISSUES TWENTY.
TWENTY NINE AND THIRTY NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA AYE HARPER.
MATHIS.
RUBIO I WOULD.
NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO BATCH
ISSUES TWENTY EIGHT AND SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ARAMBULA AYE.
HARPER.
MATHIS.
.
RUBIO I WOULD.
NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO BATCH
ISSUES SIXTEEN.
THIRTY.
SEVENTY.
SEVENTY SEVEN AND EIGHTY THREE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA AYE HARPER.
MATHIS NOVEL
RUBIO I WOULD.
NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON TO HUMAN
SERVICES.
WHERE WILL WE WILL BE BATCHING
ISSUES ONE THROUGH SIX?
ELEVEN THROUGH THIRTEEN.
FIFTEEN.
EIGHTEEN THROUGH TWENTY NINE.
THIRTY ONE THREE THIRTY SIX.
THIRTY EIGHT THROUGH FIFTY NINE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
AYE HARPER. MATHIS ARE RUBIO I
WOULD.
NEXT WE WILL PATCH ISSUES NINE.
TEN FOURTEEN AND THIRTY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA I'VE HARPER.
MATHIS NO.
RUBIO ARE.
WOULD.
HAS THREE.
NEXT WE WILL BATCH ISSUES.
TEAM AND SEVENTEEN.
IT'S CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA AYE HARPER.
MATHIS NOW VOTING RUBIO I WOULD.
HAS THREE.
NEXT WE WILL BATCH ISSUES SEVEN
AND EIGHT.
IT'S CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA AYE HARPER.
MATHIS NOW VOTING.
RUBIO I WOULD.
HAS THREE.
WE WILL TAKE THREE SEPARATE
VOTES FOR ISSUES THIRTY SEVEN
CAN WE CALL THE ROLL ON ROW E.
PLEASE.
ANDREW  ARAMBULA AYE HARPER
NOW.
MATHIS NO.
RUBIO I WOULD.
HAS THREE.
ROW H. FOR ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BROUGH AGE ARAMBULA HI HARPER.
MATHIS NOT VOTING RUBIO I.
WOULD.
THREE.
FOLLOW THE ROSE IN ISSUE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARAMBULA I'VE HARPER.
MATHIS.
RUBIO FIVE WOULD.
HAS FIVE.
THANK YOU AND THAT CONCLUDES
TODAY'S SUB ONE HERE THANKS FOR
ALL FOR ATTENDING